My name is Ji Chen
CEO of Ufoto
Since we started the company in 2016
we've published several selfie and
social sharing apps into the global market
Our first app, Sweet Selfie
exceeded 1M Daily Active Users in less than 3 months
and was featured on Google Play
As of today
the app has reached 300M downloads worldwide
Our new app Sweet Snap focuses on animated stickers
and short videos with special effects
So people can capture happy memories in a more vivid way
I'm Li Zeng, Product Manager of Ufoto
As our products are focused on the global market
the combination of the characteristics of selfies including
retouch, filters, stickers, collages, photo booth, frames, and backgrounds
requires that appropriate localization becomes key to sustaining high retention
For example, in India
we prepared stickers and collages with red Holi powder throwing effects
which let people celebrate the festival right in the palms of their hands
We use Firebase Remote Config to conduct an effective operation strategy
and use A/B Testing
to verify our design approach
Now our selfie assets have over 1M downloads per day
and they are used more than 5M times per day
The sharing rate of our selfie assets has increased by 100%
The challenge in emerging markets like India, Brazil and Mexico
is dealing with the varying
hardware specs and network connectivity
We use Multiple APKs
to publish different apks that each targeted to different configurations
We have also developed different image processing algorithms
for different device specifications
Thanks to Android Go, we are able to deliver
a fine-tuned experience on entry level phones
We removed unnecessary dynamic libraries in our app
and let it download smaller assets
if it runs on smaller screen and storage
To optimize performance, we change cache allocation dynamically
based on the size of available RAM
If the RAM is running low, a more aggressive recycle strategy will be used
Our app size is 25% smaller on Android Go
and uses 20% less RAM
After making our apps Android Go ready
Sweet Snap's DAU has increased by 465%
Selfie represents an optimistic lifestyle
These selfies with people smiling
are what drives us forward
Google Play provides us with a global stage
by giving us the opportunity to entertain Android users in different countries
We'll continue to try to discover
new ways to take selfies
and keep helping people around the world
to capture the special moments in their lives